c'est une ambiance que les européens ou
presque oublié cinq mille personnes
entassées dans une salle de spectacle
fermé face à un groupe de rock
la scène s'est déroulée hier à barcelone
où un concert pilotes étaient organisées
ravissant les spectateurs nous avons pu
échapper à la réalité pendant un moment
nous étions à l'intérieur de la petite
bulle du concert et nous avons pu nous
souvenir du temps où des choses comme
celle ci était normal des choses qui de
nos jours ne sont pas si normal
malheureusement pour revivre ces
émotions le chou était strictement
encadré les spectateurs ont dû se
soumettre un test antigénique le
résultat était ensuite envoyé sur une
application à présenter à l'entrée de la
salle si le test était positif le
spectateur ne pouvait pas assister au
concert et le billet lui été remboursés
à l'intérieur va skaff et p2 obligatoire
mais aucune distance à sion à respecter
même si les participants devaient rester
dans une zone qui leur étaient assignés
dans les prochains jours tous seront à
nouveau testés afin d'évaluer le taux de
contamination
un protocole lourd encadrés par les
autorités sanitaires
tout a été très différent de
l'organisation habituelle d'un concert
premièrement parce que chaque étape que
nous avons suivi chaque protocole a été
préparé et validé par la communauté
scientifique
en l'occurrence l'hôpital renmans
triassi puyol et la fondation contre le
sida
tout a donc été différent et adapté à
notre nouvelle époque et pour commencer
tous les spectateurs du concert
aujourd'hui ils sont 5000 à être présent
mais aussi tous ceux qui travaillent ici
tout le monde a passé un test
antigénique et seuls ceux qui ont été
testés négatifs ont pu entrer c'est le
deuxième concert de ce type organisée
dans la capitale catalane en décembre
dernier 450 personnes avaient pu
assister à un spectacle
huit jours après elles avaient toutes
été testées négatives au comme ils
disent
faut il faut faire des petits pas offert
mission donc à c'est la deuxième fois
que fait un concert avec avec cette laid
mais sur laquelle on va implémenter
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on le fait avec
5000 personnes donc si on a des bons
résultats
un obus des quatorze jours après le
concert il va falloir envisager d'en
faire un autre concert avec beaucoup
plus de personnes mais je pense que il
faut prendre des décisions fermes et
sion quand on a des résultats
après ce concert là et après le concert
qu'elle a fait à la salle apollon
désespoir prudent pour le monde de la
musique
le primavera sound et le sonar de
festivals réputés de barcelone ont
d'ores et déjà annulé leur édition de
cette année pour se concentrer sur 2022